las próximas horas serán definitivas
para la permanencia de boris johnson o
no en downing street sin más ministros
del gabinete renuncian entonces boris
johnson tendría un pie fuera de su
residencia oficial y por supuesto del
gobierno sin duda las renuncias del
ministro de salud y de finanzas que
fueron coordinadas buscan poner presión
para que johnson dé un paso al costado
porque sus escándalos ya le han hecho
suficiente daño a su gobierno y estamos
hablando de dos de los más grandes
aliados de johnson dentro del gobierno
así lo han evidenciado las cartas que le
han enviado presentando sus dimisiones
el ministro de salud ssa yo ya había
dicho ya no puedo en buena conciencia
continuar sirviendo a este gobierno
mientras que el ministro de finanzas
rich y zoom a quien también fue multado
por el escándalo del partido ha dicho el
público espera que el gobierno se lleve
de manera adecuada competente y seria
así que estamos a la espera por si más
adelante en las próximas horas hay
nuevas renuncias esto significaría
entonces que si éstas suceden las horas
de boris johnson como primero y estarían
contadas